For every 3 hours
of computer games,
Sandy has 2 hours of homework.
For every 7 hours
of computer games,
Madison has 4 hours of homework.
I guess they have to do a
certain amount of homework
for every amount of computer
games that they play.
The following graphs
describe the relationship
between the number of hours of
computer games on the x-axis
and the number of hours
of homework on the y-axis.
Which point can tell us how
many hours of homework Sandy
had if she played computer
games for 5 hours?
So we have to pick which
one of these graphs
describe the relationship for
Sandy between computer games--
that's what's going on on
the x-axis-- and homework.
So they tell us for Sandy, that
for every 3 hours of computer
games, she has 2
hours of homework.
So for every 3 hours of
computer games on the x-axis,
she has 2 hours of homework.
So it looks like that
point is sitting right here
on this red line.
And this red line,
every time the x-axis
increases by 3-- which means 3
more hours of computer games--
it increases by 2.
So there's 2 more
hours of homework.
So this red line
describes the relationship
between hours of
computer games and hours
of homework for Sandy.
So we have to look
at the red graph.
And so they're saying, if Sandy
played 5 hours of computer
games, so 5 hours of
computer games for Sandy,
you go to the red graph.
You get to point C.
So this describes it.
It looks like it's a little
over 3 hours of homework,
if she spends 5 hours
playing computer games.
Pick choice C. And it is right.